this is a production of cornell
university
so uh this this afternoon um i'm going
to
i'm really happy to share some of the
work we've been doing at the urban
horticulture institute
and what i'd like to do is set out the
focus of our
work and then discuss two areas of
research there's so many
areas like focusing on two so
the science of greening our cities
there's a lot of science to the
uh aesthetics you see
in urban environments so we're trying to
talk about those
issues uh as you can see in the title
slide that
tree ball is going to go into that
little tree pit
and next time it sees anybody's when
somebody will come
and cut it down so
we talk a lot about ecosystem services
provided by the urban landscape
and that's really true and people like
them especially the people in the forest
service and other folks
are talking about all the valuable
ecosystem services provided by
trees and soils and we see you know
storm water reduction air and
water quality improvement energy
conservation
carbon sequestration all these great
things urban heat island mitigation
habitat
and more that we cannot quantify but
there are many different
basically services that trees and soils
provide
but uh and although that's great and i
talk about it and i believe that it's
really important
my work really talks about the issues of
getting to the point where you do have
ecosystem benefits
so often trees do not thrive they are
really in a poor position so we like to
say
yes we plant trees and we get all these
benefits but my work has really been
doing dealing with getting the point to
the trees are doing their
their best and there are many challenges
to the urban environment
as you can see here a street in new york
city a tree is kind of holding on for
dear life
and so
over the years i've come to look at
our work as a process of
landscape establishments thinking that
if you do things
well at the beginning then you have a
chance for trees to actually thrive and
provide us the ecosystem benefits for
which we plant them
and it starts out with site assessment
understanding your site
i mean urban environments are so
heterogeneous that uh
it's really not something you can uh
just
categorize in one way so you really need
to see the site conditions
and then once you understand your site
you can make proper plant selection
but in some cases the site is so
disturbed and so difficult that you have
to modify the site
in order to the plants to grow so that
plant selection
site modification goes back and forth
the better you make the site
the better the plant uh will grow and
the more choice of plants you'll have
and then finally the last part of
establishment is transplanting getting a
tree into the ground
and for the first few years before it
becomes established
so our work really revolves around these
four steps
and i think you know that's the way
we're going to get the best
result in the urban environment so
uh you don't have to be downtown new
york city
to have urban in fact you might
recognize this place
um this is the ag quad when man library
was being renovated and for three years
there was a building site on the quad
and so the tremendous soil disturbance
and
root disturbance and all kinds of
problems that
went from that and many trees were taken
down and so when
all the trees and all the
all the materials and the uh trailers
were taken out
and everything was uh back to normal
the tremendous soil disturbance that
happened on that site and that
does not go away it even if you put a
couple of inches of soil on top and put
some grass
this soil disturbance is pretty
impressive
uh so site assessment really is
understanding site opportunities and
limitations and we're looking at
conley park downtown ithaca where uh
housing development was built
right uh next to it and this was the
staging area
for that housing development and when
they
basically finished the housing they said
to the city of ithaca well you can have
this and you can make a park on it
so i said okay we did that and but we
had to do many things to actually bring
the soil
back to health so that we could actually
grow plants on it
it's growing very well now
soil is a big issue of site assessment
we try to understand what's happening
with the
typical soil texture structure porosity
bulk density but also we need to look at
where the roots are
in the urban environment and so you can
see one of the tools we use
is called an air spade or an air
excavation tool and you can see these
big norway maples on the green strip
between the curb and the sidewalk and
there's no way the tree roots of that
tree would be
have enough volume in that you know six
foot wide green strip
so we wanted to find out where the roots
are and we do a lot of this work to
understand where roots are growing in
urban environments in this case we took
off
uh four inches of concrete and we
then tried to find where the roots are
because there's no way
that there'd be enough soil volume in
what you see on the surface
so uh yeah so we actually did uh find
that out
took the four inches of concrete off and
found that the roots
had actually found that area weakness
between the curve
a bit between the sidewalk and the base
course and just
made their way through that area into
somebody's front yard where they got
a lot more of the soil volume that they
needed we see a lot of this
very shallow rooting of trees in the
urban environment because of the
purposeful compaction
we find many cases so a lot of what
we're going to be
thinking about is how do we find enough
volume
for trees and we'll also how do you find
the best trees to deal with this
other issues that we deal with in the
urban
environment at the urban heat island i
don't know if someone
if you've seen our speaker last week we
talked about
you know we know about the urban about
climate change and
rising temperatures but in terms of the
urban
environment we've had increased
temperatures now for
as long as there's been urban conditions
especially pavement
and reflective heat and asphalt and
cars and that so in the interior of our
cities we get a much rice temperature
which also puts a lot of stress on trees
in terms of water loss
and water access i like this picture
this kind of shows uh
what's going on here so this is a
a picture taken with an infrared camera
and on the right you can see
that there's a scale from about 67 to
105 degrees
so we're showing the temperature of the
surfaces of this
area and you can see those kind of
columns in the back those are tree
trunks
where the shade of those tree trunks the
grass there is about 67 degrees or so
if you come out from the shade you're in
the sun grass on a sunny site
and that gets up to 82 or so and then
when you come
to that orange area right
at the bottom of the screen you'll see
that that's pavement
and if probably concrete 105 degrees but
if you're an asphalt maybe up
as much as 135 degrees so all these
pavements and pervious impervious
surfaces
reflect heat and basically raise the
temperatures in our urban environment
so what we're really dealing with is
looking at best tree selection and best
site modification so
here we see on the top left uh
london plane tree showing its true
genetic potential
giving all the basic uh resources that
it needs
and that's that's me down at the bottom
there
so it's an enormous tree and then the
same
genetic material on the bottom right
also another london plane tree in the
streets of new york city showing that
you can have all the best potential in
the world if the environment
does not allow you to get what you need
you'll be have a much shortened life
so it's the nature nurture issue that we
deal with in terms of
our research choosing the best trees and
trying to modify the site so that we
have the best environment for
our plants so plant
site selection criteria pest resistant
plants adapted to site conditions
non-invasive highly diverse meets the
design
functional objectives and matches
management limitations
now from our point of view many of those
things are procedural and
basically planning kinds of things we
can do
but when it comes to plants adapted to
site conditions
that's what we do most of our work on in
terms of the plant selection aspect
so a lot of what we deal with is drought
because of limited soil volumes
because of the hot nature of our urban
environment we have a lot of very high
transpiration rates
low water availability and even in a
normal
season we would actually have a water
stress
so we started to look at plants that
deal with water
stress or limited water availability and
there are two
basically strategies that trees use one
is avoid
limited water deficits and one is to
tolerate water deficits
and avoidances may be increased water
acquisition
deep rooting increased hydraulic
conductivity
and to reduce water uses you have
stomatal closure
uh leaf excision reduced stem and
root growth and stem and leaf growth so
those are avoidance mechanisms and
they're
you know valid but in terms of the or
urban environment we want to have leaves
on the trees
and we need so leaf obsession is not a
really good strategy
for for us in terms of tolerance so
we're very interested in looking at
tolerance those trees that can
tolerate uh stress by an osmotic
adjustment
and having a very low trigger loss point
so these are things we're starting to
look at
and we've done some work on this
particular area
so yeah in terms of uh
deep rooting and having a lot more soil
volume that often is not
possible because of the way we construct
our urban environments parking lots
as you see here the tree you know
there's only about four inches of soil
in that area where the trees were
growing and
it's amazing that it got that far to
grow that far before it actually went
over
so deep rooting is not something we can
often
expect another
avoidance aspect though it's kind of
interesting this is a great picture
on the right this is a tilia tomentosa
or silver linden
and on the left you see these amazing
trichomes that are
on the abaxil surface basically covering
up
most of the some of the stomata so
they're reducing water loss and this is
this is an avoidance strategy which is
because it doesn't cause the leaves to
lose them
to upsize and they still are functional
that's the tree onto the right
it's a really good strategy for
dealing with water deficits however we
don't have these on all trees
and even closing stomates also causes
problems in terms of less
less photosynthesis and growth
so this idea of trigger loss point as a
draw
drought tolerator indicator is something
we've been working on for now for many
years and it's kind of a universal
measure
we can measure osmotic adjustment and
calculate the trigger loss point where
trees actually can
tolerate being in the droughty condition
until they lose turgor and are become
damaged we can rank species in terms of
their physiological drought tolerance
this
way so this is some work a couple of my
colleagues and i did
a few years ago where we took 27 maple
species and cultivars and we rated them
for
their trigger loss point and the more
negative you get
the better it is in terms of trees being
able to tolerate
stress in their cells before they lose
turgor
and you can see at the bottom you've got
well i have the
dark bars are spring trigger loss point
and the lighter bars are the
summer calculations and so you have at
the top
let's say acer speccatum which has very
very
low turtle loss point an ace of
spaghettium is a tree you'll find in
the gorges of tremen and the understory
you know very uh not very
drought tolerant at all and if you go
down to the bottom you see aceremon
special anum which is from a
mediterranean
tree and acer grandin and tatum which is
one from the
arid western part of the u.s and these
have
quite good abilities to modify their
osmotic adjustment and have greater or
less
more negative trigger loss points so
these would be more drought tolerant
than the ace of spectator mesa
manchuricum on the top
and so we can rate these it's also
interesting to note
if you're looking at the species we have
different cultivars
have different trigger loss points so if
you look at
acer sacrum toward the bottom green
mountain
which has pretty high trigger loss point
and then you go up to
acer sacrum caddo or green column
their trigger loss point is much
different so we have
species cultivar differences that are
very useful when we're
choosing trees for the urban environment
so with this information we started to
look at
evaluating a long-term project this
is a white oak breeding project which we
started in uh
started the breeding in 2004 2006 and we
had
seven maternal parents then 36 pond
parents
we had 350 unique hybrids which we were
trying to develop
more drought tolerance more alkalinity
soil tolerance
and as well as good disease and form
and so on that would you need for the
urban environment
we found some really unusual things here
we found true dwarfs
we found trees that had no central
leader whatsoever
that grew laterally and we had all kinds
of different
uh interesting things here but we
started to look at
evaluate these for their ability to
tolerate drought
and so uh this this is not those hybrids
but this is showing uh
i was interested not only in measuring
the drought tolerance
with the turtle loss point but also
looking at
could we by giving trees uh
sequential dry downs could we increase
their
turgor loss point basically asking them
to step it up given a little bit of
drought
so on this these pictures you'll see on
the left is quarkus by color swamp white
oak
uh on the very far left those trees were
well watered
and then the one slightly to the right
those had gone through cyclical drought
dry downs and on the right side you see
bachelor pendulum silver birch
on the far right that had been well
watered and the one
toward the left of that had been going
through cyclical dry downs
now the birch is interesting that's uh
not considered a drought tolerant tree
and you can see why
basically when you give it cyclical dry
downs it just loses its leaves it says
i've had it i'm not going to
deal with this i'm basically going to
drop my leaves and wait for better times
on the left with corker's bicolor it
showed no
leaf drop it basically kept on
photosynthesizing
during this time even though the one on
the
just to the right of the one on the left
had uh
gone through many cyclical dry downs so
this tree
and this white oak bicolor swamp white
oak
is exceptionally drought tolerant tree
and it has the added advantage
of also being tolerant of wet soils
so this is how we measure it you can see
on the bottom three columns basically
you have
the x-axis is trigger loss point and
the you have well-watered on the
y-axis and water deficit you can see
that the bottom one which was well
watered the three
bars spring mid-summer and late summer
they
you know again you'd expect in late
summer you'd have more
uh osmotic adjustment but the one that
had gone on through cyclical dry downs
uh showed that the one that late summer
had
really changed and actually become more
drought tolerant
because it had experienced those
cyclical dry downs and was able to step
it up
so that would became more turbo loss
it had a lower turbo loss point so this
is kind of interesting to see if we can
actually
modify the way trees grow so that they
are able to tolerate
a greater uh stress
so after we were we've been looking at
these we're evaluating many of these
trees and also uh we're looking at the
same
issues where uh brandon miller's uh
karya's experiment we weren't very
interested in hickories and we're doing
some of that work with his
uh trees as well we then had to figure
out well how are we going to propagate
these trees and because these are all
clones they're all
unique genotypes and so we spent a lot
of years
early before we started breathing to
figure out how we could clonally
propagate them
and this is a quick view of basically we
cut trees down
to a few uh maybe four or five inches
to get to the juvenile part of the plant
we cover over
the plants so they're ideolated as they
grow out
they when treat the bases of the plant
with iba
shade them so they don't crisp up in the
sun
and then after we take the shade off and
we have
we add soil this mix to the
cone surrounding those trees and then we
get
hopefully rooted plants and so there you
can see the whole process
and here we have clonally propagated
oaks
uh at the end and this was great we're
very happy you published all about this
but in one year we might get four plants
which is not very good and if we're
going to try to introduce this to the
nursery
so we went a different route
tissue culture now if anybody's
familiar with micropropagation oaks have
never been really successfully
propagated through a tissue culture and
we have been working on this now for
many years
and we've had some success it's all
genotype typical
specifics so what one works for one
doesn't necessarily work for the other
but we're
have our certain trees and here's the
one tree we hope to introduce
which is fondly called 1819
but this is a three-way cross
different white oaks and we are starting
to get this to
multiply into root and tissue culture so
we have hopes that we'll be introducing
some of our hybrids that have
particularly good characteristics
in the next few years
so we had our first group of plants we
got so big we had to get them out of the
ground so we gave them to
oh about uh 100 different communities in
new york state
and each community got at least five
trees and they are very happy and the
trees are going well and we're taking
data on this and a long-term study to
see how these trees are doing in
different soils and different climates
we have trees in
laoville and zone three down to
long island in the tropics so we have
trees all over new york state that are
being
of these hybrids that are being tested
on a more observational long-term basis
so i'm going to change gears here just
to
um talk about we can look at
plant selection which is very important
and we can get better plants more
drought tolerant plants and so on
but everything really resides with the
soil you can have the best plants in the
world
but with poor soil conditions
they really will not tolerate that
condition very well and they won't grow
as well
so we had to deal with soil and soil
disturbance in the urban environment
so this is just going to talk about
our work with structural soil over the
past
20 years and this is
dealing we developed structural soil
because of the required compaction prior
to laying pavement
pavement is ubiquitous in the urban
environment parking lots sidewalks
roads and in order to lay any pavement
you have to purposely compact the soil
so you have a load-bearing surface to be
able to lay the pavement
if it's too soft the pavement will
subside it will crack
so you need load-bearing and i worked
with engineers to figure out
what they needed for this and we learned
to speak engineering during this process
so this is the kind of soil which
engineers love to put
pavement on very dense you know brick
like
it's not going to subside and of course
tree roots have a really hard time
navigating this kind of soil
so here you see uh basically the
compaction of the
subgrade and the base chorus the gravel
mix and then some reinforcement
and in the bottom of the screen there's
a square
uh which is where the tree is going to
go and the tree did go
and so the soil under that area was not
treated any differently
than the soil where the pavement is
going to go
so yes you can dig it out you can put a
tree there and then
the problem is where does the tree roots
go i mean they really have no place to
go in terms of because of the compaction
level of that side
uh sidewalk base
and so we saw we know we often say we
lower the tree into the coffin
here which is uh unfortunate
here's a four by five tree put in new
york city tree is going in
you're gonna put some soil around it and
then
the tree will grow or not grow and
typically it doesn't grow very well
so the idea was to come up with a way to
meet the engineer's specifications for
load-bearing
of a sidewalk or asphalt or whatever but
still have a
soil underneath that which could uh
allow roots to penetrate and to grow
and this was a difficult uh combination
of features to
do but we did develop something called
structural soil
and you can see in this diagram the
white
irregular shapes are represent
gravel of one size like one and a half
size
diameter and if you get one size gravel
and you
basically compact it you'll have
very large pores or voids in between
that
and so in the void we would put soil and
uh
and the soil if we have stones touching
stone stretching stones
the soil in the pores or the voids
is not compacted because the stone is
bearing
the load from on top you can think about
it as a rigid lattice or a matrix
so that the stone provides this matrix
and then the
soil is in the pores and the soil is not
compacted because
it does not feel the compactive load on
top
that's uh in this part of new york state
we uh
use limestone as our base typical cheap
stone and this is the size
stone we would use for structural soil
and then we add soils about 80 stone 20
uh heavy clay loam or
at least 20 clay by weight and this is
how it's mixed
there's a couple of other features in
that but this has been used now
many places
when we were basically exploring this
we needed to have some sidewalks to know
where we could put this
in because cities don't like you uh
digging up all their
sidewalks so we actually developed this
sidewalk so nowhere we had structural
soil
and just compacted base mixed with not
structural soil and we had
a conal tree planted on top of them so
we can look at what's going on with the
roots
and then we take them apart and that was
about four or five years later we
on take the sidewalk off you see a
little base course of gravel
tree was cut down and then we would
wanted to look at where the root growth
was
so this is using that air spade again
the air excavation tool
and we could take the roots out in one
piece
by using the air spade and that's a root
system of a
tree growing in structural soil cu
structural soil now
and we made these trenches down a meter
deep
and we could see
just how extensive those roots were and
the control was here our typical
compacted soil with a little bit of base
on top
and we excavated that as well and that's
what we found
which we find all over the place these
pancake-like roots
uh with very shallow root systems that
one on the right
just found its way down the edge of the
trench so otherwise it would not have
been
so deep but pancake roots uh very
shallow
very susceptible to drought is what we
typically find
so we wanted to study roots under
pavement
and this was a difficult thing you'd
have to go through what just what we did
taking the sidewalk off our excavation
so is there an easier way to do this so
we started working
with uh gary rafael who's an arborist
who owns a
ground penetrating radar apparatus which
you're looking at here it's like a
souped up tricycle with a
radar unit at the bottom and
we wanted to look at well here basically
there's been some new work with radar
looking at how
radar could not just look at stones and
pot shards and metal
but it could actually locate roots and
we were very interested in this
and so you basically run the machine
over the ground and the radar
will reflect a beam from roots
roots are typically tubes of water so
this is
the work that was done
[Music]
was very interesting uh to us so we
could do this
remotely not having to dig up everything
to see where the roots were you can do
it over pavement you can do it over soil
and you get a virtual trench on the
right side of the slide you see
if you're walking along and you have
depth and you can every one of those
x's is a root detection so we were very
interested started working with this but
before we got to the point where we
could say yes this works we're really
locating roots
we had to do a ground truth study to see
just where
the roots were was it really was it
really accurate
so we took our sidewalks to nowhere we
had our machine and we did scans
down on top of the sidewalk to look
where the roots were
and of course these were trenches they
were lined with heavy metal plastic so
we
didn't expect them and the roots did not
go out
into beyond the sidewalk area
and then we actually dug up some and and
had our own manual
count visual count of roots that were in
that
sidewalk area we could only only detect
roots that just
just under a centimeter diameter we
couldn't get the fine roots
but we did do those counts
and and interestingly you see on the
x-axis the ceo radar
uh radar signal count that's what it was
predicted
and on their y-axis is what we actually
counted
which is just under a centimeter
diameter roots
and it was pretty good i mean we're
getting pretty good uh
agreement between the radar and the
visual
actual what are the roots looking like
so we're feeling
confident with this we could go into
other areas to look at
roots under pavement
so here's a structural soil as we would
actually
specified under sidewalks and there's
many sidewalks in ithaca that look like
this where you have structural soil
from 24 to 36 inches deep and then where
you have the tree you have ordinary soil
with the opening with just putting
structural soil
under the pavement
and this has been done there's actually
1 500 installations of this all over
north america this is in brooklyn uh
after 12 years here the structural soil
at the top
left going in not just in those pits but
continuously in a trench
you just see the openings there and then
after
three years and after 12 years those
trees doing
exceptionally well
here in ithaca on state street
uh you have elms planted
and growing exceptionally well in
structural soil there
and even an olympic site in sydney where
when the olympics were there
i was talking about this in san
francisco one year and
the developers of the olympics were
there and they said oh let's try it
theirs i didn't know anything about this
but they used structural soil
for the big plaza where all the athletes
would gather
those are oriental plane trees growing
in structural soil
and in miami beach sure palms and
structural soil
why not uh the roots get depending how
you
do design the structural soil the roots
can actually go for
much wider area and having a greater
structural
integrity
so the roots actually don't trees don't
blow over in storms which they get very
often there
but we first started look at the
combination of things
using porous pavements and structural
soil
more and more pavement gives rise to
uh flooding downstream
you see this this was actually route 81
a few years ago
and we thought the problem we could
combine structural soil
with porous asphalt to get trees to grow
to
basically have water going back in the
ground and trees
growing in paved sites
we could do this because um
the porosity of structural soil so the
total porosity after compaction okay
this 95 to 100 proctor is an engineering
term for compactive effort a standard
compactive effort
you would need to lay pi pavement on top
of it
so structural soil you have 26 porosity
because you've got such big stones
and soil alone you've got more porosity
34 percent
but the macropores and structural soil
after compaction
about 31 macropores and in soil alone
you've got about 2
macropores so the infiltration rate
of structural soil is greater than 24
inches an hour or be less than
half an inch an hour on normal soil that
has been compacted
so we thought well okay if we have the
structural soil we can put it under
uh porous asphalt we can get
infiltration
right through the profile into the
groundwater
so this was a parking lot
a pull-off next to the trail near the
inlet that the city wanted to improve
they allowed us to make this a trial
parking lot with structural soil and
porous and non-porous asphalt
so we took the entire parking lot and
put about 30 inches of structural soil
and compacted it
and then we put half of it in porous
asphalt and half and traditional
non-porous asphalt you can see
the difference in porous and non-porous
asphalt
so then in uh november 2005
we saw cut into the porous and
non-porous al
asphalt and there was structural soil
and we bare root planted
elm trees in this parking lot
my students of course do that here it is
the first year
that first spring of 2006
trees were small growing we put them in
small
notice the big yellow barriers because
this was one and a half inch caliper
trees
and i could see the snow plows just
taking them out so
i put the berries there but this is
after
about another four years they're growing
well
and 2012 still well they're shading this
parking lot now uh and here's
uh last october uh
doing quite well so uh we wanted to see
what was going on with the roots
and we were noticing that in the
non-porous side the trees were somewhat
smaller
than the porous side now they all had
structural soil but
there was porous and non-porous asphalt
on top
notice the trees on the right are
somewhat bigger so we did some work we
looked at
tree growth for uh from 2000
for six years and the black bars
represent
those trees in non-porous asphalt with
the gray bars are the poorest asphalt
and you see the years and over time from
2012 to 2018
we're getting less and less growth this
is shoot growth
in the non-porous asphalt paving but in
the porous asphalt we were
basically no change it was growing uh
you know 15
to 20 inches every year
so what's going on with the roots so
again we took our ground penetrating
radar and we were looking at what's
happening with root growth feeling
confident that because we did our ground
truth study
we could actually be optimistic that we
were seeing the real roots on the ground
without having to take everything up and
destroy it so there's uh
you see three and four those are trees
in
non uh porous asphalt and there are six
scans on either side
which are the scans of the um the ground
penetrating radar
radar and on the right side there's
trees eight and nine which are in
structural soil but in porous asphalt
and another six scans
uh of ground penetrating radar
so this is what we saw each of these
panels really is
as like a a scan from
about five inches down to 35 inches
and a long uh 35 feet area and so each
one of these red
dots is a root that we uh
found and this was uh
basically this is a non-porous asphalt
so the roots were
didn't go down as far as we might hope
but they were there and
and this is where we looked at it when
we looked at porous asphalt
this was the root signal we got under
the other trees so we were getting roots
way down deep a lot more roots it seemed
and this was encouraging in terms of
getting more water into those trees
another way of looking at it is if you
pancake the roots right to the surface
not looking at depth this is a color
root density chart where you can say
we have bluer colors green colors are
very few roots where you get to the
orange and brown
you have a lot of roots so this is the
root scan
of non-porous traditional asphalt this
has been
roots if you pancake them right to the
surface
and this is the root density of
roots under porous asphalt so a lot more
roots just as we saw with the scans
but a considerable number of more roots
so if we look at it
from basically looking at where the
roots were and the porous asphalt which
is
the gray bars you had more
at the surface eight inches and
basically about the same
non-porous the porous asphalt the roots
in the middle
but where you really have a tremendous
differences the roots go down
deep in under porous asphalt and that's
where you had the greatest increase of
root growth
and total you see you have quite a bit
more root growth in
porous versus non-porous asphalt
so i'm getting to
the end and i basically want to
reiterate that there's
the issues of tree selection and
soil modification soil of remediation
are the key
factors to getting a success of trees so
they can give us the ecosystem benefits
what you're looking at here is a plaza
in new york city
called zuccotti park and
these trees are growing all in
structural soil underneath that
concrete the trees on the other hand are
really good trees for urban environments
they're the honey locust
oh i would like to see more diversity
the trees are doing well
people enjoy the park uh it's the
success of soil and tree selection
together
because although we like structural soil
that has
good attributes for underpayment there's
a compromise and that
the available water holding capacity of
this very stony mix
is between eight and ten percent which
is low so we have to choose trees that
are more drought tolerant that be able
to
uh mine for root for water
within this structural soil
profile so with that i will
allow some questions that they're
running and that's my website where
there's lots of
information about all the different
projects we're doing
outreach research videos
please feel free to enjoy that website
fantastic well thank you nina very much
for that uh comprehensive look at
all the work that you've done in
enhancing the urban environment
now is a great time for questions so if
you have any questions we can go ahead
and get started with that i don't see
anything in the chat
feel free to write them there or just
chime in i have a question
uh very nice presentation
dr pastor i have a question about the
pancake type troops that you talked
about
do you see a lot of wind damage to the
trees where they fall down because of
the roots being in the top layer or
compared to the ones yes in fact people
do ask me
[Music]
that aren't trees and structural soil
more apt to fall over i think in fact
that's not the case because
trees and structural soils go down deep
and they go very wide
so you can think of a tree with
two arms out tree trunk with two arms
going out the more
surface the roots are the more
susceptible they are to wind
throw and wind damage and you see this
lots in the
after hurricane or after wind damage
you'll see the very pancake like nature
even in the
in forested areas where roots may need
to be in the surface area because of uh
denser layers below so in fact in
structural soil we can get roots down
deep which
is going to be hopefully better for
reducing that wind throw problem
brandon i have a question yes
and nina really enjoyed your seminar
thank you
just wondering um are there
stress tolerant root stocks available
uh are they rarely used or
you know i can see that stress tolerant
rootstocks can definitely
play into this well well
they're obviously in you know apples
cherries um
there are the fruit crops there are root
stocks that are
clonal and give different aptitude
attributes but with the
basically with uh all these ornamental
plants typically the
clonal uh cyan is grafted onto a
seedling
ceiling okay so there are very few
there's a couple
in the crab apple feel where they're
basically uh
root socks that don't sucker those are
clonal but
most of these trees are grafted or
butted onto a seedling
that would be nice to see if we can get
that too but uh
that has not been done all right
thank you so much for the great talk i
had a question
about um
should i type it in the chat can you
hear me no no no no please come back i
can hear you
great um i had a question if you think
that like using the structural soil as a
remediation method would be possible for
reducing some of the
drastic seeing in a lot of cities
especially as like sea levels rise
if that could be a method to kind of
delay
um like mean space
to capture that runoff water well
we do use structural soil as a bioswell
because it has so much porosity even
when compacted it has
basically 25 porosity so
you can use it as a in a bioswell i'm
not sure about sea water
we'd have to deal with salt but
for flooding it is a it can be a
reservoir
under the soil to actually capture a
considerable amount of water because the
infiltration rate is so
fast that it captures that as long as
the surface is porous
so that it will uh capture it and then
allow it to go into the ground water
over time
so this is used in in bioswells
just typically just gravel under
bioswales but
using structural soil you could have
roots grow down deeper
to actually use this
use the water that's down there if
diameter your question i'm not sure
about seawater that's
that's a whole nother ball of wax in
terms of
uh tree tolerance of seawater
awesome thank you you're welcome
nina the can you comment on tree
planting
along stream sides specifically cayuga
inlet
well uh for the last 10 years my class
has been planting along cayuga inlet
[Music]
the ithaca garden club has
a project where they're planting crab
apples along the inlet
and typically it's my class every fall
that
plants 15 or 20 of them
is there another issue in terms of what
comment about the inlet it's channelized
it's not kind of a
gradual edge it's uh
it's a you know it was the army corps of
engineers who developed the inlet
uh to prevent flooding and so there are
many trees now going in
um other than that i'm not sure if
there's another question there
perhaps if um they can clarify if
they're looking for something else there
is another question in the chat
have you done any work with herbaceous
plants uh
annual plants in the structural soil and
also grasses
i've grown shrubs in it woody plants but
i haven't got
grown herbaceous plants i would expect
that many of the more drought tolerant
grasses especially would do really well
in structural soil i mean again
all of these plants no matter what
herbaceous or woody would have to become
established first
before you let them go because uh
when you transplant something the roots
have been compromised they've been
restricted and now you have to let those
roots grow
before the plant takes on the attributes
of what you planted so i would imagine
though i've never tried it that
herbaceous
herbaceous plants will do well on the
other hand why would you want to do that
structural soil was only engineered to
be under pavement
and that's the reason to do it if you
don't need to use
that load-bearing soil don't do it
there's other ways of remediating soil
that
where you don't have to put the
load-bearing for pavement we're just
talking about load bearing for pavement
when we talk about structural soil
is there a significant additional cost
using structural soil
well structural soil is uh pretty cheap
considering it's just
uh heavy clay loam loam soil
and gravel with a little bit of hydrogel
sprinkled on the so anyway basically
it's somewhere in that we
range about 50 dollars a cubic yard
[Music]
the real cost is the excavation
so if you're dealing with a new
streetscape and you want to put
structural soil in
you have to excavate you can't just you
know basically rough up the first six
inches and put a tree in
uh you have to give it at least 24
perfectly near the 36 inch depth to be
able to have enough volume
of soil and water to support that tree
where people have done 10 or inches of
structural soil i said you know
save your money don't do that because
there's not enough depth so
the real cost is the excavation if it's
new construction where that's not an
issue because it's already
part of the deal then the real cost is a
pretty
pretty minimal considering of the cost
of building
so that's where
that's where that stands
we have a clarification for the question
about the um
the inlet okay so the cayuga inlet has
poor water quality because it's
channelized
how can tree plantings help improve
water quality in the channel
i don't know if they can the trees that
are planted on the inlet are
you know quite a ways away from the edge
i mean unless you're trying to get roots
into the water to take up sediments
uh i mean the roots of the trees on the
banks will hold that bank but i don't
see my experience a lot of erosion into
the water
there probably is the sedimentation is
coming from upstream i would imagine
but where we've planted right downtown
in ithaca
it doesn't appear that there's much
erosion from those banks
and to that extent the trees will help
that i
you know other than that i would have to
do more exploration to see
where the poor water quality was coming
from
okay i um i don't see any other
questions right now
so thank you dr basic for your fantastic
presentation
thank you brandon and thank you
everybody for listening
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu